hey everybody I'm backstage here with
mr. Joel Stein
this is $5 of you before this is for
your own personal collection I've never
seen this does that what do you do with
these things
just keep it on my desktop and look at
it when I'm lonely really yeah that's
weird you don't do anything weird with
it you know okay just look at it when
I'm willing yeah it's a layered and Huff
your book man made change things in
America changed America for the better I
want to say other people say differently
we call it a stupid quest for
masculinity but I think that you have to
be pretty secure in your masculinity to
say that you're going on a quest for
masculinity how do you respond to that
sir I say I live in a community which
does not value a masculine to do that
much so I can afford to be
self-deprecating about it I'm a
journalist live in Los Angeles I think
if I were a lumberjack in the wilds of
Saskatchewan I wouldn't have the guts to
do well you wrote this article about
Silicon Valley about defending for
business would go for Businessweek did
they cover on like programmers basically
program yeah I have not heard that you
read someone I like but I want to know
what you think about the there was a
story this week about women or company
is paying their employees to freeze
their eggs they're female yes yeah where
do you come down on that it's like a
good thing like because a lot of people
are saying that it's that they're doing
it because they just want these women to
work all the time and not have a life
and freeze the eggs and make a baby any
family that I find in general when you
ascribe
reasons people are doing things to them
they're usually accurate I think they
have a lot of women there we do in Los
Angeles a certain demographics we're
older and maybe not ready to have kids
you're not married yet there's a big
career-focused or just haven't gotten
married and so I think it's a service
they're providing can you so I don't
think they're doing on purpose yet when
they work lawyer right can we look at it
societally and say that maybe we haven't
done a good job I was deciding making it
easy for women to have both occur in a
family definitely but I wouldn't like
blame Google for that I don't think
they're like we can keep them here
longer freeze their eggs I just I never
there maybe they have that in them deep
down but that's not what they're
thinking with me try and help people
right we're such dicks basically after
someone does something we're always like
yeah they're really doing it for money
yeah that's what we always say we
ascribed such evil to people in their
brains early on it's not accurate so
angry about this straw man I built ah
hey strong men are the worst there are
horrible and separating The Wizard of Oz
we term it really isn't so thank you so
much for coming in diagnostic this is
gonna be great on my desktop
next time I'm lonely I'll bust it out
and just reminisce it's wonderful time
we had together
no thank you see you next time good see
you